the crisper cast 9 system is a tool for
cutting DNA at a specifically targeted
location the technique has already
revolutionized gene editing but
scientists are always looking for new
possibilities so what else can CRISPR do
since being discovered in a bacterial
immune system CRISPR Castine has been
adapted into a powerful tool for genomic
research there are two components to the
system a DNA cutting protein called Cass
9 and an RNA molecule known as the guide
RNA bound together they form a complex
that can identify and cut specific
sections of DNA first cass 9 has to
locate and bind to a common sequence in
the genome called a perm once the pam is
bound the guide RNA unwinds part of the
double helix the RNA strand is designed
to match and bind a particular sequence
in the DNA once it's found the correct
sequence Castine can cut the DNA it's to
nuclear's domains each make a neck
leading to a double strand break
although the cell will try to repair
this break the fixing process is
error-prone and often inadvertently
introduces mutations that disable the
gene this makes CRISPR a great tool for
knocking out specific genes but making
double strand breaks is an all CRISPR
can do some researchers are deactivating
one or both of cass nines cutting
domains and fusing new enzymes onto the
protein
cast line can then be used to transport
those enzymes to a specific DNA sequence
in one example cast nine is fused to an
enzyme a deaminase which mutates
specific DNA bases eventually replacing
site adine with fiber dean this kind of
precise gene editing means you could
turn a disease-causing mutation into a
healthy version of the gene or introduce
a stop codon at a specific place but
it's not all about gene editing several
labs have been working on ways to use
CRISPR to promote gene transcription
they do this by deactivating cast line
completely so it can no longer cut DNA
instead transcriptional activators are
added to the cast 9 by either fusing
them directly or via a string of
peptides alternatively the activators
can be recruited to the guide RNA
instead these activators recruit the
cell's transcription machinery bringing
RNA polymerase and other factors to the
target and increasing transcription of
that gene the same principle applies to
gene silencing a crab domain fused to
the casts 9in activates transcription by
recruiting more factors that physically
block the gene
a more outside-the-box idea for using
CRISPR is to attach fluorescent proteins
to the complex so you can see where
particular DNA sequences are found in
the cell this could be useful for things
like visualizing the 3d architecture of
the genome or to paint an entire
chromosome and follow its position in
the nucleus CRISPR has already changed
the face of research but these new ideas
show that what's been achieved so far
could just be the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to crispers potential
whatever comes next
it seems the CRISPR revolution is far
from over
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]